[Music]
this world can make you feel alone
sometimes
but i think the most important thing to
do in life is always be there when
somebody needs you
i had been driving by him for almost
three years
he would stand there
rain or shine
i decided i needed to stop and find out
why he was there
i stand right there on that corner my
mother would meet me there sometimes
whenever she could
that's just a place that she could meet
me if ever she was looking for me
because he couldn't find her he just
wanted to make sure
she knew that he was okay which i
thought was so beautiful
he has this wisdom that comes up from
inside of him that can only come from
love that is just unconditional
[Music]
we were getting phone calls from people
who were saying get this guy off your
corner every one of my crew would check
on him on a daily basis
[Music]
some would go in the morning and check
on him and then go back in the evening
he'd ask us how we were doing and we
would ask him how he was doing and what
he needed
he stood on the corner people gave him
money but he didn't want the money
victor said i'm just waiting on my mom
and as soon as we told all those people
the story
the outpour
from this community
was enormous
[Music]
last thanksgiving when i drove up on the
corner where he was i think he had
enough food to feed probably five
families
it was all spread out all over the
ground and he was just standing there in
the middle of it
there were so many people in our
community that cared about him but he
didn't need another sandwich he needed
that next step
it was at that point that my husband
said you know i really feel like he
needs to come and stay with us this is a
lifelong journey
victor is part of my family
he has a mother one is enough he told me
and so we've decided that i'm the big
sister
it's like coming home and
you just try to be a nice person there
because you treat people like you like
to be treated you told me that you were
my gift yeah i i am your you you know
yes you are yeah because yeah if you
believe only if you believe
we've gotten to know so many people in
our community because of victor
a dentist did a tremendous amount of
dental work for him a karate studio gave
him tai chi lessons
we're a close-knit community we take
care of our own
victor was one of our own
victor and i we stopped and cared about
each other that's what friends do
friends come and go so you need the ones
that are going to stick by you
[Music]
you